Eh bien bonjour les amis comment allez-vous ?
Il y a quelques jours j'ai sorti une F.A.Q.
Dans laquelle je répondais à vos questions
Puisque c'est une foire aux questions c'est le concept de la vidéo
Et en cherchant des questions pertinentes je suis tombé sur une question qui a attiré mon attention
La question était la suivante :
Sais-tu que tu as une fan base sur la relation entre Maxenss et toi ?
Pour plus d'informations, vas faire un tour sur Instagram.
Alors, j'l'ai pas mis dans la vidéo parce que j'me suis dit "Attend, là, y'a un truc surpuissant derrière"
J'ai fait deux trois recherches Google et effectivement y'a un vrai délire
Entre Maxenss et moi et aujourd'hui on va découvrir tout ce délire en vidéo avec Maxenss, le grand l'unique !
Maxenss : Ah je t'aime. Oups, pardon, fallait pas que j'le dise !
Squeezie : Il y a des gens, qui s'amusent à dire que nous sommes secrètement en couple Maxenss
Ok.
*Bisou sur le cou*(on se pose des questions)
Et ça, ça m'blesse beaucoup
Ca m'a pas blessé hein
*Rires de corbeau*
Il faut qu'on mène l'enquête Maxenss
Qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire, d'où ça vient
Je te présente le compte Instagram "Luxenss"
Qui comme tu peux le remarquer est la fusion parfaite de nos deux prénoms
Oui ça marche bien c'est aussi une marque de peinture.
Alors, je sais pas pourquoi ces photos là particulièrement
Mais je, j'ai, l'imp.. regarde, par exemple là, on peut apercevoir un contact tactile imminent.
Et j'ai l'impression que ça les excite beaucoup
ou qui v'nait d'se faire...
*blanc + petit rire*
On va découvrir cet univers photo après photo
Ouuh y'a des vidéos
Oh la y a des vidéos mec c'est incroyable ! "Ils sont trop mignons !"
Mec je sais pas si t'as remarqué mais au tout début ils avaient pas encore trouvé Lucaxenss
et ils avaient trouvé un truc qui sonnait un peu moins bien M: Ah oui y a le hashtag Lucacens ah pas mal
La page s'appelle encore lucaxenss hein ! S : Oh t'es chiant tu gâches la fête là
Putain ! M : c'est vrai que c'était une super fête, super ambiance
Ooooh y a une vidéo *son de la vidéo*
Il y a eu un contact tactile et je crois que ça leur a plu
Nan mais j'étais fixé sur mes cheveux moi excuse moi j'ai pas capté...le...
Narcissique ! (lit) on en parle de ces yeux qui brillent? Blblblblb
C'est vrai que tu as l'air très amoureux de moi hein
Si seulement ils savaient que deux jours avant cette vidéo tu m'avais trompé...
Nan mais on va pas régler ça en vidéo
Mais tu parles de quoi?
Bah deux jours avant je t'avais grillé, avec Martin
Mais il s'est jamais rien passé avec Martin
Beh eh mec t'es venu avec lui, Martin! Viens
Ah okay c'est un tribunal! T'es venu avec lui. Tu m'as appelé pour meeeeeee
Me juger devant les gens ça y est
Nan mais regarde ce qu'il fait !
Mais c'est juste un massage. Martin, tu sais, il a l'habitude de
Me soutenir et tout, il me masse quoi.
Mais arrête de toucher toi!
Là, pour le coup (begaye), pour qu'il me soutienne, faudrait qu'il soit en-dessous
Ouais, attend t'es en train d'insinuer que vous avez fait l'amour ?
Nan
M: Oui ! S: Nan Martin là tu peux dégager...
Ma puce !
Waaw ! M: Waw j'ai une très belle tête sur cette photo
*lit* J'avais pas vu sa main. Ah ! Parce que apparemment j'avais la main mal placée
Attend nan c'est vrai attend j'ai raté un truc
Oh ta main est sur mon épaule. Mec ta main est sur mon épaule !
Qu'est ce que tu fais avec le casque ?
Nan rien... il avait ton odeur. Ton odeur de nuque
"Leur sourire" Nan mais y a plus rien quoi ! Juste on sourit sur une photo
Carlito : Maxenss, donne nous un compliment sur Lucas
Lucas tu sens bon...
Maxenss, tu as de beaux cheveux
Cela m'a ravivé des bons souvenirs
Ah ça m'allait bien les cheveux courts hein ?
Sais-tu ce que ça t'fait dire ça ?
C'était un de nos plus beaux moments
J't'en voulais parce que la veille y'avait encore eu ce.., ce Martin qui...
Arrête de toujours ramener Martin c'est chiant...
Mais naaan, mais mec c'est... M : - Mais mec c'est juste un pote
S : - Mais c'est pas ma faute si tous les jours y'a des messages de Martin dans ton téléphone
Behh c'est un pote on s'envoie des messages
Ton pote tu lui envoie des cœurs tous les jours ?
Tu lui mets "Je t'aime" avec un emoji cœur ?
Y'a pas d'soucis ? M : - Mais j'ai jamais envoyé ça !
Mets ton code. Tu lui as dit : "Hein."
MAIS M*RDE MAIS TU FAIS EXPRES MAXENCE !
Mais y'est malade *rire*
Mais tu dis pas "Hein" à un pote ! Tu dis "Quoi", tu dis pas "Hein", "Hein" c'est personnel !
Je m'excuse. Je dis attend : "Désolé, je t'adore"
Mais tu lui dis p... Mais c'est dingue
Mais t'es en train de te justifier ça montre bien qu'il y a un blem  !
Là j'dis, j'lui réponds : "On se voit très vite", trois points de suspension de j'sais pas trop quand on se verra
Trois petits points comme si tu savais quand est-ce que t'allait le voir
Le trois petits points veut dire je sais quand on se voit mais on va pas le dire ici parce qu'on cache un truc à Lucas
Behh je.. attend je remet
S : - Renvoie un message
Ah, il m'a répondu: "ca marche j'ai hâte de te voir"
Bon bah j'lui dis... donc point d'exclamation
S : - Attend attend.. j'vais, j'vais j'vais j'vais j'vai... M : - Attend, j'lui met quatre points d'exclamation
Et j'lui met des clins d'oeil
Par contre il m'a répondu c'est un peu chelou là
*Musique acoustique*
M : - Ben euh... S : - C'est vrai que souvent t'aimes bien regarder par dessus mon épaule comme ça genre
Bah là en fait j'crois qu'j'regardais euhh... tu me montrais une photo
Ouais
S : - C'est la première fois que tu me touchais l'épaule. Franchement, c'est ce qui m'avais séduit d'abord
*bégaye* 'Fin, c'est, c'est c'qui avait fait qu'on était devenus potes 'fin j'avais kiffé euh
'Fin ouai après la photo suivante elle est cool
*lis* LOOOVE
M : - Ma coupe elle m'allait bien. S : - Ouais
*lis* "Le bonheur dans les yeux de Maxenss" Ouais parce qu'on était à Kyoto
T'étais content juste parce qu'on était à Kyoto ?
Bah ouais c’était ouf
Ouai mais moi j'ai, 'fin j’étais *bégaie* avec toi 'fin ça a pas cont... ça a pas contribué ?
Bah si ça a contribué parce que sans toi j'aurais pas pu y aller quoi.
Et c'est tout ? C'est juste matériel entre nous ?
Bah non, c’était cool, t'es un pote- t'es un bon compagnon de voyage
J'cutterai j'cutterai mais... tu... 'fin nos moments à deux *chuchote*
S:- Oh c'est pas mal !
Put*in il s'est fait ch*er
ça m'a pas fait rire *rit* Si, ça m'fait rire
Si, ça me fait rire bordel
Maximeuh !
Ooh !
T'as fait exprès !
J't'ai vexé hein ce jour là, ma puce
Ouais Luc'
*Musique: Faded de Alan Walker en version accélérer*
Attend on est d'accord qu'y a- Qu'y a *ris*
C'est la vidéo accélérée avec du noir et blanc
Y'a vraiment pas différent extraits quoi
*lit* "Ils sont ensemble ? Je débarque"
C'est qu'à mon avis, ça faisait un moment qu'on avait pas fais d'apparition "publique"
Aaahh *Lucas comprend*
S:- On se cachait M:- On faisait seulement des apparitions privées
S:- Nan, enfin nan nan. On a jamais fait d'apparitions privées
Bah si quand on... fait des soirées entre potes quoi
Naaaaan... *bégaie* Oui, oui voilà, en amitié ouais
C'est ça une truc privée, j'parlais pas de...
*parle bas* De quand t'es venu dormir...
Ah c'est une autre vidéo !
M: Il est beau ton tatouage
S: Ah c'est pour ça que tu touche là
M: Oui oui c'est vrai
*lis* "Ce genre de regard vers Lucas"
C'était un moment où je riais beaucoup et du coup vu que t'étais pas loin et..
C'était marrant, bah je te regardais, quoi ... Joyeux Noël à
tous
"lit": Merci pour tout, ca fait seulement 2 semaines que j'ai ce compte et j'ai déjà fait des rencontres formidables
@maxenssjust. bigup. @maxenssklan. bigup. @lu.cbae. bigup.
@lu_compte_fan. bigup. @lucasmaxens. bigup
@xsqweezy. bigup. @wholerian.mp4
"Rire"
Elle est ouf la chute ! Y'a aucun rapport, c'est génial !!!
*Musique*
Cette image est...
Cette image, elle a fait fantasmer tout ces gens
*musique*
Avec de la fumée
S:Franchement. M:Pas mal. S:Trop stylé. M:En plus c'est bien parce que
T'as mis plein de coupes de cheveux que j'ai pu avoir. S: Maxenss t'as un sérieux problème avec tes cheveux. Règle-le !
*musique*
M:C'est quoi du coup ce... S: Sa ! C'est du... C'est du cachemire !
S: Qu'est ce que tu fais ?! M: Non, je regarde la matière. Elle est cool ! S: Non, tu cherche un contact tactile. Je le vois bien.
Le but, là, c'est de se moquer du truc
pour justement, donner tord à ceux qui croient sa. C'est pas d'avouer. Faut se moquer. Faut qu'on se moque ! M: Oui mais je faisait... S: Genre "Ah ah ah" c'est des oufs
de croire que c'est possible...  AH !
*musique dramatique*
M: Non, ça c'est pas possible ! S: ça vas super loin !
M: ça c'est pas passer sa ! Et le montage il est fort, hein, bravo ! S: Attends mais mec
c'est incroyable. Ils prennent le temps de faire des montages tellement crédibles !
Oh! Mais mec, c'est sa la vrai photo ! M: Ouais c'est ouf ! S: Y'a vraiment un délire à propos de nous deux !
M:Bah, continuer c'est marrant en vrai... S: Bah me dire qu'ils peuvent imaginer que
éventuellement on dort ensemble et tout, c'est marrant , quoi !
Puis euhhh... Si c'était le cas, euh...
Enfin euh... je kifferai pas de ouf, quoi !
M: Bah non ! Bah dormir avec des potes, oui ! Bah sa arrive quand même !
Genre nous on tourner quand on est en tournée avec VSO avec Martin.
S: Ouais. M: Souvent on à la chambre à coté. S: Quoi ?!!!
Attends, tu dors avec Martin pendant que tes tournée ?!!!
M: Bah, y'a qu'un lit. Des fois c'est un lit. S:- Y'a qu'un lit mais y'a pas qu'une chambre dans un hotel !
ça tu me  l'avais pas dit !
M: Est-ce que j'ai besoin de te dire ce détail ?
S: PARDON
Tu dors avec quelqu'un excuse-moi ! Est-ce que moi je dors avec Jonathan ?
M:- C'est qui Jonathan ? S:- C'est un pote comme Martin
S:- Maxence connais-tu Wattpad ? M:- Oui..
Je connais depuis 2014 parce que y a des gens qui avait écrit une fanfiction entre cyprien et moi
Mec je suis sur et certains qu'il y a des fanfictions entre toi et moi
Ahlala, "Dans mon lit" (?)
Lucas qui passe son temps à publier
Attend mec... Y'a... 11 chapitres....
J’espère en tout cas que la personnes qui la fait, déjà bravo, tu nous en voudra pas trop de le feuilleter.
Surtout de ne pas l'avoir acheter.
*lis* Maxence ouvrit doucement. Il était seul dans le lit de Lucas
Ce dernier devait déjà être levé
S: J'allais dire c'est elle qui savait pas écrire, c'est moi qui sait pas lire
*Maxence lit* "Bah alors qu'est-ce que t'a lu' ?" Dit-il avant que Lucas ne l'enlace. "Oh vient te coucher j'te prépare du thé, on en parlera"
"Okay" Répondit doucement Lucas dans le cou de Maxence.
*Maxence pouffe*
C'est fou ce qu'il sentait bon, un mélange de fleur et de chupa chups. Étrange mais tellement apaisant.
Lucas retira son pantalon et se glissa dans son lit.
En t-shirt et caleçon. Maxence le rejoignis, les tasses en mains. Il les posa sur chacune de leur table de nuit. Retira lui aussi son jean et se mis dans le lit aux cotés de Lucas.
Ils prirent chacun leur thé et commencèrent à boire.
Maxence n'eut pas a demander a Lucas quoique ce soit. Il commença a tout lui raconter. Il écouta attentivement.
S:- Au moins... M:- Non c'est moi je crois S:- M*rde *ris*
M:- Au moins tu n'as plus à te soucier de votre relation et de vos sentiments. Maintenant tu vas t'occuper de ce qui te rend heureux,
Hein ? Ne pense pas à tout ce qu'il vient de se passer" Dit Maxence en posant sa tasse vide.
S:- "Ouais. Et puis, tu reste avec moi ? Hein ?" répondit-il en posant lui aussi sa tasse de thé
M:- "Évidement", dit-il en s'approchant de lui
S:- "Je peux avoir un câlin ?" demanda Lucas en souriant
M:- Et viens là
*ensemble* "Ils s'endormirent comme ça, dans les bras l'un de l'autre."
"C'est fou ce que d'enlacer quelqu'un pouvait illuminer un esprit"
"Lucas se sentait en sécurité, bouillonnant d'aise et d'amour"
"Tandis que Maxenss dépose un baiser"..
M:- "Alors Maxenss s'avança. Il attrapa le visage de Lucas de ses mains tramblantes"
"et déposa sur ses lèvres un simple baiser."
L:- "Au début, Lucas ne savait pas comment réagir"
"Il restait immobile, les yeux clos. Il eut du mal à réaliser ce qui était en train de se passer"
"Il ne s'y attendais pas, mais si c'est ce qu'il voulais depuis des semaines, après réflexion"
"Il avait longtemps douter et penser qu'un tel baiser éclairerais ses sentiments"
"Mais là, maintenant, il n'était pas encore sûr d'aimer Maxenss
"La sensation que ce baiser lui procurer était..."
"Alors, sans trop réfléchir, il répondit doucement au baiser, posant ses mains sur la taille de Maxenss."
"Et une forte chaleur s'installa en eux. Le baiser s'intensifia
"et une explosion de sensations se fit ressentir au plus profond d'eux"
*Maxenss imite un explosion*
"Les deux garçons se perdaient et se donnaient l'un pour l'autre, dans un baiser pourtant si innocent
M:- "La porte du studio s'ouvrit soudainement et un cris de surprise se fit entendre"
*font semblant d'être supris*
C:-"Lucas ? Max ?" S:- demanda Carlito
"Son visage affichant une émotion de choque mais aussi de joie"
"Ces deux derniers ne savaient plus où se mettre, les joues rougis par leurs baiser et les cheveux..."
"en bataille.."
M:- C'est comme ça pour toi les cheveux en bataille
S:- Oui *ris*
C:- "Les gars vous êtes ensemble ?"
S:- "Oui" M:- "Non"
S:- "Lucas et Maxenss répondirent en même temps. Ils se regardèrent, doutant, sans comprendre, puis répétèrent"
S:- "Non" M:- "Oui"
S:- "Maxenss regarda Lucas en souriant. Ils s'étaient compris."
"Ils étaient un peu perdu mais étaient en quelque sorte ensemble"
"Lucas sentait qu'il devenait de plus en plus rouge"
S:- Attend je me fais rougir
M:- Arrête, non, faites pas ça chez vous
S:- Ah oui tu peux mourir
C:- "Bon les gars, je vous jure qu'avec David on attendait que ça"
M:- "les faisant sursauter"
Pire qu'une fangirl
S:- "Bah je, je, heu..."
M:- *voix off* "Lucas avait l'air plus gênait que jamais bien qu'il était surpris"
C:- "C'est pas méchant Lucas mais oh la la ! C'était à la fois attendu et inattendu."
M:- *voix off* "Lucas regarda Maxenss et vit qu'il souriait lui aussi
S:- *voix off* "Il lui pris alors la main, hésitant. Maxenss enlaça leurs doigts"..
M:- Ok
S:- Comment t'enlace un doigt ?
S:- *voix off* "En souriant de plus belle avant de suivre Raphaël"
S:- Ouais c'est bon c'est fini, alors pourquoi t'étais comme ça face caméra ?
M:- Ah je suis désolé, tu sais bien que, heu, je sais pas.. c'est dur à dire devant les gens comme ça, j'ai du mal, je
S:- Ouais mais tu sais c'est moi qui fait le montage là, tu pouvais quand même être un peu plus..
M:- Ouais mais *soupir* S:- Fais moi un bisous
M:- Je t'aime S:- Moi aussi, tu m'a manqué ma puce
Faudra quand même que tu m'explique qui est Martin.
*Musique et Outro de fin*